housing condominiums on the west side of
town are set to be torn down those
living there say the demolition has
already started and they have nowhere
else to go Madison Kimbrough joins us
live near Bonanza and MLK tonight with
the story Madison
yeah if you've been to these
Condominiums you'll see that it looks a
lot like a ghost town take a look behind
me as tenants are leaving left and right
but many feel like they are being pushed
out even being offered money for their
keys we're giving you a live look at
what's going on here as of now as you
can see tons of trash debris broken
windows and doors tagged many say that
they were told that this demo was
happening just a month ago while the
reason behind the demolition is unknown
tenants say this complex has been
problematic for years now Antoine who
lives in this area and has for two years
has been saying that it's been really
nothing but problems with the lack of
notice given to tenants and it's put
everyone in a frenzy
they're not trying to push nobody out
well I mean I I believe people would do
a demolition when there's no one here
right so I I don't I don't get how
you're able to do a demolition and it's
still a tendency
some other neighbors we spoke to over
the phone say the owners of the
Condominiums that's Ahern Rentals have
provided an agency to help relocate
tenants but the process has been less
than helpful now we plan on reaching out
to the city to get more information as
to why desert Garden is being torn down
and what the time frame is like for
these residents who still reside here
coming up at six o'clock and then 11 we
plan on talking to more of these
residents who say that this area has
just been so problematic but the fact
that they're being pushed out is really
their biggest concern right now because
they really have nowhere else to go
reporting near Bonanza and MLK Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now